[Music]
there are many universes and many earths
narration also if you'll allow me to
translate what the narrator means to say
is we're about to do some crazy
imagining in this movie but don't worry
the multiverse exists so we get a make
up stuff that makes no sense card deal
are we going to see the child talking
animals also one minute in and I already
want to be watching another movie that
involves James Bond fighting alongside a
leopard so many worlds but connecting
them all is dust along with many many
young adult cliches one can only assume
also could the narration be more
mind-numbing feel like I'm on Spaceship
Earth learning about the Phoenicians
dust was here before the witches of the
air
the Egyptians of the water and the bears
of the ice jeez movie we aren't even two
minutes in you've already exposition my
brains out with talking animals soul
sidekicks dusty world connectors and
three different element based races let
a girl breathe will you in my world
scholars invented an le feel meter a
Golden Compass roll compass one compass
remains however and only one who can
read it only one person can save the
entire world and that person is a child
cliche who's doing what to who know
there's a curse on this gate Egyptians
ought to know that
that's gypsy list crossing this game is
worse and touching someone's dinner with
your bare hands it's time for the demon
questions chapter one we already know
that demons and their people feel each
other's pain but how does that work if
your demon armadillo gets run over does
its master die too if a dog has his tail
stepped on where would the human feel it
if these are spirit guides that are with
the person at all times does that mean
at all times and are they doing the same
thing their human counterpart is doing
for instance does one have to have two
toilets available in all bathrooms when
someone is showing someone else how
their golden compass points are the
partners demons doing the same thing or
do they just have to watch I'm honestly
not sure which situation is more
disturbing no one will be seated during
the dramatic Lord Asriel looking at a
marble dramatically portion of the movie
I love dispensed with centuries of
Tolerance free inquire if you needed
further proof this film did not take
place in our world or in present-day
I guess no one has noticed or cared
about the broken glass and poisonous
brandy all over the floor dust is
flowing into this man from a city in
another world invisible intangible
inaccessible incomprehensible
inconsequential inedible I wouldn't
recommend it to pie gentlemen it's cold
I'm not sure which makes less sense bond
with a beard is just now getting around
to warning people not to drink poison
his brandy or that he didn't immediately
turn in the person who poisoned it as
soon as he knew I will not have my nice
slithering round like an alley cat and
so begins demon questions chapter 2 do
animals exist that aren't demons could
one have a pet along with their demon
how would one know that an animal is
simply an animal and not a demon will
this movie give us any answers or just
keep bringing up fantastical terminology
at least I'm pretty sure I can answer
that last one what do you know about
dust damn Daniel you're the one that
told to stay in the closet while you wax
poetic about the powers of dust so of
course she's gonna be curious Larimer
yeah the tutor of metaphysics tells me
that you've missed your lesson again I'm
glad this movie is differentiating
itself as much as it can from other
young adult novels a great dining hall
the music cues discount Dumbledore
chatting with the girl who lied about
her metaphysics class this movie just
went full on Harry Potter and I don't
even think it cares if we know it this
is cool time there's an old saying that
goes something like whenever in a khole
Kidman and there's a room all the men
rise I believe Billy Bob Thornton said
it
you mean the master that's sitting about
three feet directly in front of you and
clearly able to hear this conversation
what a movie characters speak as if only
the audience can hear them as a matter
of fact I have had an audience with the
backing himself I even brought him and
his family some cokes and then found out
they were really in a Pepsi and that's
what I learned that I shouldn't believe
everything I see on TV let me deal with
this real you mustn't deny me this
little thing you really mustn't and by a
little thing she means kidnapping
because this is kidnapping and welcome
to demon questions chapter three is
demon cuddling this world's version of
playing footsie under the table to the
Masters always know what their demon is
doing why does some demon speak English
to their human counterpart and some just
make animal noises what if your demon
ends up being an elephant or a fish some
poor kid is just treading water his
whole life wondering how I got stuck
with a demon grouper now we're Jaca
being also this movie is chock-full of
reunions Daniel Craig and his dead James
Bond girlfriend Ava green Ian McKellen
and Lord of the Rings Co wizard
Christopher Lee Kristin Scott Thomas and
her Gosford Parks Coast
they're Jacobi also also with ian
mckellen and ian mcshane this movie is a
single home maybe even a mile come away
from completing the Ian trifecta
if he succeeds improving the existence
of these other worlds it will come to
dick centuries of teaching I guess but
also these people would be part of the
discovery of other worlds and
interdimensional travel so win-win also
if they lead this metaphor for the
Catholic Church on and the thicker it
would be frozen molasses with a Pope's
hat on top also known as a Golden
Compass reroll credits I guess we're
doing demon questions chapter four is
this type of dog always your demon if
you work in the house service industry
does your demon relate to your
profession seriously demons man
how can a movie be both overly
expositional and still completely under
explained people also travel by solid
metal dirigible in this alternate
universe because apparently the laws of
gravity and physics also work completely
differently luke pan he's got loads of
pictures round the edge no reason for
the headmaster to explain all that I
guess just give Valera the compass and
hope for the best
and while you're at it you must learn to
control your demon now who's doing what
to who now because apparently you're the
Saviour in this episode of Harry Potter
and the lord of the never-ending
stardust of ember the airbender and
wardrobe demands a general ablation for
g o be godless seems like a stretch but
sure encyclopedia blonde why not so did
curious demon george just wait for Lyra
to get out here before going after her
because he was already between her in
the window and could easily have gotten
to her before now who threw that net on
her
these gobbler knobs somehow know this
was where she was going and one of them
was just waiting inside or was it the
egyptians at rescue her later by the way
none of this makes any sense but what
are you doing here we've been in your
shadow ever since you left jordan
cottage watching over him okay fine but
how exactly did you know she would need
you at this place at this moment she
literally just escaped from the cold
kidnapper man mere minutes ago movie
decides ripping off Harry Potter isn't
enough and throws in some Pirates of the
Caribbean for good measure it's a truth
measure a Golden Compass
RiRi roll credits I'm sorry but there's
a rule in the cinema sins holy texts if
you have three legit roll credits
moments in your first half hour of your
movie you automatically get an extra 33
cents so say at the faith rhinos of the
Sahara mist lands and so it shall always
be by pointing at three symbols
you can ask any sort of question you can
imagine but some bulk right there what
if I really want to ask it why every
time I masturbate I get angry and throw
a half-eaten carried at my pet turtle
Theodosius exactly what three symbols
would I use for that huh this is Kota
are you familiar with the prophecies of
the witches oh dear God how much of this
expositional bloat am I supposed to
remember it'll be a quiz is there any
way to understand any of this without oh
what's the phrase for it again
oh yes reading the book a secret like
bees tiny and they literally have a
Golden Snitch Whoopi has decided a
Potter so hardcore I'm surprised it
doesn't have clay all over its hands
spelled odd kingdom of the eye space
Tennessee House with the sins oh I
thought we were just playing that game
where you're by yourself and you
randomly announce the location you're at
my name is Sarafina Pecola clan queen of
the witches of lake Inara and I am San
Frisco cinema tiger clan king of Goku
soft your hand can I go up in your shape
considering all the that has happened
with Lyra when she wanders off with
strangers you would think that she
wouldn't be so eager to run off with
another one at this point Lera deserves
whatever happens to her without my but
you're also a bear bear right so bear
the doubt of this village and get the
armor back a bad arm is who so as your
demon is your soul like for real or
metaphorically I swear is unflinchingly
abstract as this movie is I honestly
can't tell I will say the CG animal
effects of this kind of astonishing
there's a reason this won the Oscar that
year for visual effects I wasn't
planning on taking a center for it but
since it kept a pirate's movie and a
Transformers movie from claiming the
Oscar scene traction well deserved
I didn't realize going into this movie
we'd be watching a lot of the story
unfold through the actual fucking Golden
Compass there's but be too hasty
yeah see if there's no need for a
dust-up but there are several more men
with guns that could turn around and
shoot Roadhouse also I like how Sam
Elliot turns any movie he's in no matter
of the genre into a Western that's some
pretty fast work miss Lera
yeah I'm struggling to keep up so let me
see if I have this straight space cowboy
Whistler here is now working with the
giant pocket watch girl the egyptians of
the caribbean polar bear gandalf and a
Vesper the witch cameo to go save a
bunch of kids and the professor from
evil Satine and her band a petty priests
all because of something we were just
calling dust do I get that right carry
on I guess one way or another it's
better that I've said missus Kuta after
the child she has to hire a standing sag
card among us
another hydrogen fire not trying to
belabor this point but I really think
Sam Elliot thinks he's in a Lonesome
Dove sequel yes don't take kindly to
trespassers oh man where I do read this
reminds me of that episode of Star Trek
Voyager where the crew feels they have
to travel through Borg territory to get
home even though they could have
probably figured out anything else that
made sense regardless Janeway decides to
make a deal with the board for safe
passage which in turn kills off
countless species this really has
nothing to do with the movie but I just
wanted to point out the Captain Janeway
is a homicidal maniac
also wouldn't this be a great time to
use the compass to see if there's any
other way to get where they need to go
back Birds really I mean maybe you can't
tell right away that they're witches but
there's no way you were mistaken those
giant witch shape objects for birds
that's indecision
that's what the goblins are doing I'm
actually beginning to think this entire
script is exposition otherwise known as
going full Tolkien you never go full
Tolkien come on with me we'll take you
someplace safe fine Lyra finds a kid out
in the middle of the frozen pond and
they discover the whole gobbler
separating the demons from kids
sub-block but one of the chances of all
the kids kidnapped it's one of the two
Lyra knows as Sam Elliott Sam Elliott's
a couple of these whatever they're
called dudes we see their demons
instantly disintegrate does that mean
they're dying the moment they're hit by
these bullets none of them even take a
few seconds to bleed out so much
something tells me this movie would have
been at least 100 percent better if it
was solely an adventure film focused on
these two characters I'm not a witch's
theming great king I can go as far from
him as I please over an hour into this
movie and all this world building banter
seared into our brain and yet this
conversation might as well be in another
language for people told to bring the
CliffsNotes version of Philip Pullman's
book with them to the screenings yay
another CGI battle where everything is
evenly matched and we'll have no clue
how one character overpowers the other
one like they predicted the MCU a year
in advance
isn't the jaw-dropping conclusion to
this fight a bit graphic for a pg-13
film I mean I'm not complaining it's
just the MPA and it's constant epoxy
what is the spice it's called the
Experimental Station what do you do here
that answer would seem to resign in the
name of the place Lera they're not even
trying to hide it they took many costs
that way last week and he's still gone
don't
I've got a plan right you maybe also
don't I mentioned that you found Billy
you know maybe put his friend at ease a
bit no rather just leave him to the
torture the unknown then use this one
they'd quick so this evil kid prison
just lets the kiddos wander off through
the building with no supervision even
schools have hall passes
come on movie we needn't be concerned
with the Lord Asriel I mean oh god yeah
I kind of figured that since he's barely
been mentioned or seen since the first
15 minutes of the movie I swear if this
character wasn't played by Daniel Craig
I wouldn't have remembered he was in the
movie and would have thought they were
introducing a new character with 20
minutes left you never give us a pop
don't you
well she's how you grow up but we've
seen that it alts have demons as well so
not sure what any of this means
seriously cuz this movie I'm glad we
have a couple sequels to let us in on
everything that happen in this one and
oh what's that
so wait she's been carrying around that
death beetle in her purse for this long
for just such an occasion that's some
pro level convenience thing if I've ever
seen it is the old flip a bunch of
switches and throw toaster net trick
that's all we sure to word vs. ex
machina also where did he come from that
no one could have noticed he's a giant
looking bear that not touch me oh hey
it's Chekhov's which we saw about an
hour ago for like 30 seconds it's like
ex machina is on top of ex machina is up
in here ex maka deception well now at
least we know where Twilight Breaking
Dawn Part two got the idea for its snow
filled CGI battle as they say if you're
going to steal steal from something
there's a prophecy about that child she
will decide to the wall which is to come
you mean like in the sequels sequels but
if Azrael finds a way to travel between
worlds nothing will stop them from
trying to take over then why exactly was
the magistrate not a fan of Azrael going
on this journey in the first place and
while this hub up over getting the
compass just let him do his thing then
step in and take over if he succeeds I
want to know what does this
so do we since that's all the characters
talked about for the first 30 minutes of
the film and then it became all about
ice-barrier hierarchies and child labor
uprisings sing-off all sorts out and
none of it will be because you made a
whole movie out of explaining the world
spouting out weird concept civilizations
and names and not a single moment
actually resolving any sort of the story
it's like a world where someone made a
movie out of the summer lien and never
followed it up with the Lord of the
Rings I haven't been this disappointed
since I pour a bowl of Fruity Pebbles
and then realize
was no milk in the house where's the
milk movie where's the freakin milk
we'll set it right man just let them try
to stop us they didn't need to domestic
box office numbers took care of that my
name is Eve Eve Moneypenny I look
forward to our time together Miss
Moneypenny
how you doing there dude